it's really hard to describe how
difficult the circumstances are for
living out here in Skid Row there are so
many people who are battling mental
illness a lot of people got triggered
just by seeing us with our cameras we've
seen syringes in this street we've seen
feces in the street you can smell the
lack of Sanitation so not only is this a
major homeless crisis it's a public
health crisis and a mental health crisis
too
[Music]
when you hear Los Angeles you probably
think movie stars beaches and endless
shopping what you don't hear though is
that this is ground zero of America's
homelessness crisis I'm on Skid Row
which is the epicenter of it and I'm
about to tour these 50 square blocks
where folks have hit rock-bottom LA's
homeless population is exploding the
number of people living on the streets
and in shelters has soared by 75% in the
past six years there are up to 60,000
homeless people in LA County on any
given night the largest concentration of
them live here on Skid Row a sprawling
tent city in the heart of downtown LA a
UN official described living conditions
here as shocking Suzette Shaw has lived
on Skid Row for six years she used to
live in the shelters but now has a
government subsidized apartment I asked
her to take me on a tour of her
neighborhood all of these people in this
very condensed population again where do
you see trash cans where do you see
water fountains where do you see food
law enforcement they don't like the
tents up during the day but then look we
have all of these people like out here
on the concrete that are subjected to
the heat and the Sun and it's all the
other ills of the street just a block
away police closed off the street as
workers conducted a massive cleanup of
the sidewalk tell me what we're seeing
right now so this year are the hazmat
street cleaning teams that come out and
they do street cleaning and it's a
periodically done they have been known a
time to confiscate people's belongings
from their prescription drugs too
sometimes people have like birth
certificates and all of that mixed in
but along with that people are carrying
a lot of other personal items that are
deemed hazardous and therefore they end
up throwing them away the street
cleaning is done ostensibly to stop the
spread of diseases as living in these
encampments poses several human health
risks there are only nine public toilets
for about 2,000 unsheltered homeless
people on Skid Row most don't have soap
toilet paper or paper towels porta
potties used to be here and they took
them out
they recently you know installed a
couple of more but there's been a it's
been a huge fight and pushed back from
the community in regards to the fact
that there's no public toilets where
people suspects worse because people
supposed to go the lack of Sanitation
largely contributed to a deadly
hepatitis A outbreak that started in San
Diego and spread to Los Angeles last
September on top of that the streets are
littered with needles that get reused
further increasing the risk of spreading
diseases like HIV and hepatitis C it's
estimated that more than half of
homeless people in LA County struggle
with substance abuse and about a quarter
suffer from mental illness life
expectancy here is 48 years compared to
the average American who lives to 78 the
homelessness crisis is made worse by a
cycle of people going from prison and
jail to the streets they don't qualify
for food programs housing and so forth
and so then that puts them at the mercy
of being on the streets and once here
they face further criminalization from
law enforcement we saw a heavy police
presence on Skid Row and while it's
meant to deter violence and crime
residents here feel targeted police give
tickets for minor things like jaywalking
and when people fail to appear in court
an arrest warrant is issued
[Music]
oftentimes former inmates with mental
illness end up homeless without access
to medical or psychiatric help the death
of 43 year old Charlie Coonan who was
previously treated in a prison
psychiatric hospital brought this issue
to national attention in 2015
Charlie was shot and killed by LAPD
after a confrontation over a suspected
robbery the situation quickly escalates
when officers forced Charlie out of his
tent and tase him
they take him to the ground and that's
when police say he reached for an
officer's gun prosecutors said the
officers acted in self-defense and a
police commission ruled that they were
justified in the shooting Suzette took
me to the spot where Charlie was killed
obviously maybe we should have had a
mental health team out here to maybe
help the situation before then we chose
to pull charlie Kunal out of his tent
tasered him and then kill him women are
a growing population on Skid Row nine
out of ten women here have experienced
physical or sexual violence in their
lifetime I actually felt preyed upon at
times because if you're a woman living
out here then you must be you must be a
prostitute you must be a whole women
have to become tough to survive Skid Row
even with each other
the irony of Skid Row is that it exists
against a backdrop of glittery downtown
LA the area has rapidly developed and
gentrified in the last decade trendy
cafes high-end lofts and upscale
restaurants have popped up everywhere
and buildings are being converted into
luxury housing all of this is driving up
rent prices and making apartments
unaffordable Adam Murray is the
executive director of the inner city Law
Center he works with people who are
homeless on Skid Row and helps them
fight evictions and find permanent
housing why do you think the homeless
population is exploding the way it is
here I'd say more than anything else
it's the disconnect between people's
incomes and the cost of living in Los
Angeles from the past 15 years the
median rent has gone up by 28% in Los
Angeles and the median rents our income
has gone down by 8% so you literally
have hundreds of thousands of people
every month who are struggling to pay
the rent and then when you add in those
other factors that are going on in their
lives there's just not a safety net to
keep them from ending up on the streets
is the city just not doing enough in
your opinion the city is definitely not
doing enough the county is not doing
enough individually we're not doing
enough communities aren't doing enough
in 2016 LA voters passed a ballot
measure to provide 1.2 billion dollars
in funding for the construction of
10,000 affordable housing units over the
next 10 years but where to build them is
now the problem part of the challenges
is a lot of resistance NIMBY resistance
not in my backyard resistance to any new
housing that goes in especially
affordable housing that needs to change
the American homeless population
increased last year for the first time
since 2010 on any given night about half
a million people in the US were living
on the streets or in shelters meanwhile
President Trump and congressional
Republicans want to cut spending on
social safety net programs including
federal housing assistance in his budget
request Trump included work requirements
for people who receive public housing
subsidies food stamps and Medicaid he
also proposed cuts to housing voucher
programs that have helped people like
Suzette find a stable place to live
Skid Row is an extreme case study
example of homelessness in the US and
how for now the problem seems
intractable most people here are
chronically homeless meaning they've
been living as such
at least a year or repeatedly what do
you think is really misunderstood about
a place like Skid Row we oftentimes
pathologize poor people we see them as
lazy we see them as not really China
yeah we don't see the resolve the
resolve that it takes actually sustained
out here to have hope when there is no
hope I've met women who are nurses
Stanford graduates that come from
families I miss people who are connected
to celebrities living out here and we
lack the scene that these people are
actually human that we're human because
I live here hey guys it's Deena and I'm
on Skid Row so that's a glimpse of LA's
homelessness crisis make sure you check
out the rest of the videos on our
playlist for our direct from